here
okay
thank you
fascinating
yes
so
[Music]
you are okay
like
good evening everyone
welcome welcome welcome
please find a seat
everybody just kidding brett no i'm j
you're fine you if you want to stand
there i think you're allowed so
i'm so glad y'all are all here this
evening whether you're online hello
listening in the future how's it going
or here right with us tonight so
grateful
um following the service tonight there's
a welcome to the table class that'll
answer any questions
or concerns that you have about this
community and who we are and the um the
pillars that we have built this church
upon
um so if you would like to learn more
about that hang out after service we'll
start about 15 minutes after the service
ends they'll last about an hour and
there's gonna be pizza so
you just got about 10 extra sign ups
right here on the front row all
children's ministries coming to the
welcome to the table meeting can we join
us
speaking of services we're not going to
be having a service on may 29th two
sundays a year we take sunday off to
give all the volunteers a break so do
not come here on may 29th plan something
awesome and go do it that weekend and
bask in the glory of god
um
y'all i was thinking today about this
pastor or youth minister pastor that i
grew up with going to church camp and he
always every time all week he would we'd
all get together and he would say this
speech about we're all here for a reason
right here you you you you're here in
this moment for a specific reason and it
kind of got old but it's kind of sweet
you know you're like okay i get it here
we go again we're all here for a reason
but i was thinking about that tonight
for some reason i haven't thought of it
in years and i
truly feel tonight or if you are online
or listening to this later there is
something that is curated in this
message or in this worship set or in a
smile from someone here that has been
curated and made just for you
so i i'm just going to be praying and
hoping that you would find that little
nugget of beauty and soak in it and know
that
you are on the mind and heart of god and
this service from the greeting at the
front door to the worship set to the
sermon to the children's ministry to the
lessons in there they have been
thoughtfully made
to love you and to open your eyes and
soften your heart and to to come to know
jesus and the love of god and in a
community where you are welcome and
wanted
um with that being said we're going to
enter into a time of worship and i have
this beautiful call to worship that i
want to share with you so if you'll
stand
i'm going to read this you can close
your eyes
sway back and forth raise your hands
whatever posture you need to take but it
is a really good one so
if you will
listen with me
lord jesus
desire
desire is what i need
holy desire
a desire for more than the silly and
petty things i often find myself wanting
cars clothes the esteem and admiration
of others give me a desire for you
for love
for a peace that goes deep in my bones
and changes everything and everyone i
encounter
make me holy
not in the religiously stuffy sense not
in the tired and ego driven sense but in
the truest and most human sense make me
beautiful on the inside that is what i
need what i long for at least on my best
days so today
while i'm in my right mind
in my sanest moment
this is my prayer
give me divine desire
deep desire
true desire
holy desire
in the name of christ the one who
satisfies all desire
[Music]
amen do you guys sing this out with us
sing it again
amen
[Music]
in the darkest place
where the spirit of the
lord i am free amen
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
i am
[Music]
is
with the blood of christ
[Music]
amen where the spirit of the lord is
there is freedom
i am free amen
[Music]
is
oh
my
[Music]
free at
i am free at last
[Music]
everybody i am
i am
[Music]
there is freedom
i am free amen
seek it out
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
i am free amen
[Music]
[Applause]
our kids are dismissed to go to kids
ministry
[Music]
you broke my chains of sin and shame and
you covered me with grace
[Music]
it is for free
you
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
oh
yes lord we are grateful for your
[Music]
grace lord we are grateful for your
grace
[Music]
you are
i am
[Music]
that i am
oh
[Music]
would you guys read the prayer of the
people with me and if you're joining us
online please feel free to leave
whatever you're carrying on your heart
tonight in the comments and we will
share that with the rest of the room
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all who live in
them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for the prisoners and the captives and
all who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
i'm sure you guys had those moments
where you just
you kind of messed up
and you're
really upset with yourself and
um you didn't really mean to do that
thing you did
it hurt somebody
so
um i was singing this next song it was
just a repeating
pattern that says here's my heart lord
speak what is true here's my life lord
speak what is true so let that like be a
mantra for you as we
sing this song
together
and um
yeah this is also about surrender
god you are in control
[Music]
do
heals my heart
he is my
[Music]
speak what is true
he is my heart lord
he is my heart
[Music]
is
i am yours
i am love
[Music]
i have life
i can't breathe
[Music]
is
i am healed
i am
[Music]
you endure
you are good
[Music]
always
he is
[Music]
is
he is my heart
[Music]
speak what is
i am healed
i am
[Music]
always true
you are alive
breaking through
[Music]
here
what is true
[Music]
speak what is true
scott would you rewrite the tapes that
are in our head
that are full of discouragement or lies
or shame
would you rewrite that
[Music]
would you show us how even in our
biggest mistakes
you were there with grace
you are there with unconditional love
god even when we walked away
when we were lost
when we were confused
when we were in darkness
even there god would you show us
how you were the light breaking through
[Music]
you are the lifeline
that never leaves us
you are the friend you are the parent
you are the guide
calling us forward
you are the one who always sees the best
in us
created before we were born
you know the good that you planted
you believe in us god
even when we have not believed in you
would we have that deep sense
of being known and loved tonight
would we live from that place of
security would we interact with our
friends
our co-workers
our children
our partners
as people who are loved and known
god would we offer that same grace and
beauty to the world around us
continue to do your good work in our
heart god
we need it so badly
and we're grateful for it we're so
grateful
you are a good god you are full of love
god would we find that to be true
tonight and this week
even in our darkest moments god
we sense that light
always present
[Music]
thank you jesus thank you for this time
thank you for these people
and this space together it's in your
name i pray
amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us if
you want to sit down and turn to the
people around you welcome them and brett
will get us started on our message
well good evening grace and peace
uh welcome to the table it's super good
to be with all of you and uh as always
that um includes those joining us online
we love you all and um and anyone here
who is new just kind of making your way
you know in i know it can um
take a lot of courage walk through those
doors and enter in just a new space new
people um and can be a little
overwhelming so um thank you thanks for
being here
so we are um just kind of making our way
through oh actually before i jump into
this series um i need to mention i
forgot to edit the announcements and so
forth kelly announced that there was a
welcome to the table class we're gonna
push that until june um just so we can
have a few more folks sign up so um at
any rate that will not be happening
after this service tonight
there will not be such a thing
i know they're like where's the pizza
we were promised pizza
um
so okay so coming back to our series uh
is titled first peter part three or
basically just walking our way through
um this book and that's um beautiful
challenging
um all the things it's it can be really
powerful to go through an entire book of
the bible um
but uh challenging because there's all
sorts of of stuff in the bible um if
you've never read the bible i think
sometimes the like the reality of it can
be quite different than the imagined
um i don't know like because a lot of
preaching happens on like the greatest
hits
you know like the best david you know
slaying goliath you know or whatever i
don't know whatever the famous the big
hits you know and um
but there's like other stuff in the
bible you know some of it quite
mysterious sometimes very strange
sometimes um quite beautiful and
everything in between so that's kind of
what we've been experiencing as we've
we've gone through this book so we are
now into chapter four
and um
so i want to go ahead and read this is
verses one through six and by the way
the the title of my message tonight is
the consumers and the consumed the
consumers and the consumed hopefully
it'll make a little more sense later
so uh peter writes this so then
since christ suffered physical pain you
must arm yourselves with the same
attitude he had and be ready to suffer
too
for if you have suffered physically for
christ you have finished with sin
you won't spend the rest of your lives
chasing your own desires but you will be
anxious to do the will of god you've had
enough in the past of the evil things
that godless people enjoy their
immorality and lust their feasting and
drunkenness and wild parties and their
terrible worship of idols of course your
former friends are surprised when you no
longer plunge into the flood of wild and
destructive things that they do so they
slander you but remember that they will
have to face god who stands ready to
judge everyone both the living and the
dead that is why the good news was
preached to those who are now dead so
although they were destined to die like
all people they now live forever with
god in the spirit
so um there's there's plenty to to cover
in this passage if you're interested or
curious about the kind of judgment talk
um you can kick me an email i've kind of
covered some of that in previous
messages and i'm not going to be getting
so much into it tonight um instead we've
kind of focused more on versus uh two
through about four but um i want to
start here so
there's a there's a rolling stones song
so i've heard i wasn't necessarily like
i didn't like grow up on the stones i
don't know anyone grew up with the
rolling stones like
tell some of your y'all are like a
little nervous to raise your hand like i
know yes i'm old enough to have grown up
on the stones you know um
so the song that um
that that came to me is is there um i
think this was like one of the early
hits is i can't get no satisfaction you
ever heard this one yeah it's like
classic um
so here's the core i'm gonna i know it's
a little bit ridiculous to read song
lyrics but i'm just not gonna like belt
out mick jagger here like i'm just
no no for sure not um so i'm just gonna
give you the core here's the chorus i
can't get no satisfaction i can't get no
satisfaction because i try and i try and
i try to try i can't get no i can't get
no um the first verse when i'm driving
in my car uh when a man come on the
radio he's telling me more and more
about some useless information supposed
to fire my imagination
[Music]
verse two when i'm watching tv and a man
come on and tells me how white my shirts
can be kind of hear modern advertising
there you know how white my shirt's
gonna be but he can't be a man because
he doesn't smoke the same cigarettes as
me
what a rockstar um
verse three when i'm riding around the
world and i'm doing this and i'm signing
that and i'm trying to make some girl
who tells me baby better come back maybe
next week can't you see i'm on a losing
streak
because i can't get no i can't get no i
can't get no satisfaction of
satisfaction the satisfaction of
satisfaction i can't get no i um
i think this song really beautifully
captures like modern culture even though
i know it was written quite a while ago
a few decades but um you know we live in
in a consumer culture
and um
i think the the kind of the message the
he's i think he's just naming really
powerfully the kind of restlessness of
modern life you'll notice i read all the
verses
because i wanted you to kind of give a
little feel for like the different
things that um the stones are kind of
touching on so first he's talking about
um
kind of the consumption of information
right he of course mentions the radio
since that was like the primary medium
back in the day um some of you probably
still occasionally anyone still flip on
the radio in their car like i'm just
gonna listen to random music i don't
we'll just see whatever it gives me you
know okay some of you yeah for you know
others maybe do podcasts or youtube
or netflix special i don't know we're
right we take in content that's what we
call today you know content i need some
content some new content and uh this is
kind of what we do but what are we doing
we're like consuming the information the
ideas the content um
and a lot of it's useless as he names
you know it's like we tried to find the
good stuff but a lot of us just sort of
like i don't know especially like 24 7
news is just kind of like churn churn
churn churn churn you know just like
and we're just kind of
taking it in second verse he names um
the consumption of products that's the
one where he says watching a guy on tv
probably commercial right how white my
shirts can be
maybe for us today maybe it's whiter
teeth
maybe it's a faster car
bigger house you know but there's like
something like we want to consume we
want to take in those those products and
it like i don't know it touches
something within us we get that like
little moment of happiness you know when
you've like bought the thing
and it's like oh my gosh i'm gonna be
different now you know what i mean i
remember especially like i guess as
adults you get a little bit more jaded
with it like you kind of know
this won't last you know but at least as
a kid you're like no no no
this is gonna be the thing like i got my
nikes or i don't know whatever and it's
like you know this this sort of hope you
know for salvation
in uh products the third he names um
experiences he's sort of describing the
standard describing flying around the
world um there's sort of an illusion
probably to like you know trying to get
someone to sleep with them and but
there's sort of travel and sexuality and
people and kind of you know consuming um
experiences and
um
it's interesting though because at the
end of all those verses right the course
of course
does not say
i'm doing this right i'm a rock star i'm
living the dream
and it's just been
fantastic and honestly i know all you
you know fans like you can't live this
kind of life but i'm living it and it's
just great i'm loving it i'm happy i'm
fulfilled there's nothing better than
being a rock star right of course that's
not all the chorus instead it's somewhat
disappointingly
it's like and i can't get no
satisfaction like and i love the
repetitive nature of i try and i try and
i try and i try like it's just this it's
just so perfect for consumer culture
because we're just running chasing right
the next the next product the next
experience the next thing like the net
just try and we try we try we try
but we can't get no satisfaction right
it's like it's not it's not
working um now you ask what does this
have to do with that passage and i think
that the key line is um in verse two
where peter says you won't or in other
words you don't need to
spend the rest of your lives
chasing i think that's the key word
chasing your own desires because isn't
that what this is ultimately about it's
desire it's sort of desire run amok
you know we're just
hungry
thirsty in a poetic sense you know i
mean like for anything
like just
chasing you won't have to chase your own
desires but instead you'll be anxious
only for one thing
to do the will of god
you've had enough
there's something really powerful
actually i think it's the uh the the the
dow de ching that says uh there is no
calamity like not knowing what is enough
and i think that's really wise
like
so he's basically named at some point
you reach a place where you're like
you've had enough it's just enough
of what of the evil things and he just
goes on to name
things you know the sleeping around and
lusting
feasting and drunkenness and basically
just eating too much drinking too much
wild partying and then he mentions their
terrible worship of idols um and i think
he's just basically naming right like at
some point you reach you breach the
place where you're just done all the
things that it's
not it's not only early life but it's
often i'll say that often early life
teens 20s
you know that we're like
we well we still have that hope of like
it's going to work
i am go i'm going to find satisfaction
in the like i'm going to chase it and
i'm going to catch it
you know what's it well it's a little
vague but it's you know
happiness
joy
peace
all right and so we're we're chasing so
these he's naming the these things we
did
teens and 20s and at least openly at
that point maybe later we kind of pick
up a few addictions and vices that kind
of continue to haunt us you know
throughout but uh but it's you know
we're kind of chasing these things but
at some point we've had enough i'm
thinking now of um
if you're you're into like some of the
the modern neuroscience and stuff you
know they talk about um scientists and
are talking a lot about dopamine you
know those those hits that that flood of
dopamine that happens on the brain and i
think you know we could hear the passage
like i don't know he just sounds a
little bit like a killjoy you know you
won't you won't have any parties anymore
you know it can sound a little maybe
silly but i think what he's naming is
just that addictive side like it's the
shadow side
of all those things right the things to
excess because i mean if you know
anything about like um for example peter
was jewish right so jewish culture is
like all for a good party with drinking
you know i mean like it's so he's not
there like no don't you dare enjoy
yourself or i don't think that's the
heart i think he just he knows right
there's like a line
there's this place where we cross into
addiction and chasing and craving and oh
and it's just like in our lives starts
spinning out of control and so he's just
naming like at some point
you reach that place and and um whatever
the
angle is for you right whether whether
it's gambling or sexting or gaming or
facebooking uh or food or drugs or 24 7
news you know anything to distract
ourselves from ourselves we all have our
vice of choice um
but he's just names at some point it's
like it's exhausting and it's never
ending the way if you're notetaker we
might just sum it up like this um you
can jot this down um it's not a
coincidence that the age of consumption
right in list consuming is also the age
of addiction and anxiety
a restless age
right maybe it would be easy to maybe
see those um or to wonder like well why
is that
you know but i think
you can see that it's well it's it's
connected
right it's it's one leads into the other
because we're chasing chasing chasing
chasing chasing and that that mode
um produces an addiction produces um
endless anxiety but at some point you're
done right and you realize like okay
this is not working this is a terrible
life like i started off thinking this is
gonna be great you know and i realized
like oh crap this is awful
and uh it's then um
your friends have some comments i love
how he mentions in verse 4 uh how do you
put it of course your former friends are
surprised when you no longer plunge into
the flood of wild destructive things
they do so they slander you i talk
behind your back um
i uh it's interesting that willishness
loves a group you know like come on like
let's
just imagine a group of people like wait
what
you're you're not gonna be an idiot with
us anymore
come on man i thought we were friends
you know um
but at some point you got i kind of
choose your path you know and um
again there's probably good and bad ways
to do that i don't think we'd be like
jerks in the name of like well i'm a
christian now so i can't you know we
can't hang out just i don't know it can
get weird but um
but at another level um sometimes there
are boundaries right that have to be set
like i just can't go that road anymore i
just i just can't how will we go down
um
i got that language of being consumed
from a theologian named william
cavanaugh in a wonderful book
called being consumed and i want to read
you a quote by him he says this to
consume the eucharist which is um the
practice will engage actually just a
little while with communion right coming
to partake of the bread the wine the
body blood of christ to consume the
eucharist is an act of anti-consum
in other words the opposite of
normal consumer culture consuming it's a
it's a practice of anti-consumption why
for here to consume
right to take in the bread the wine to
take it in
is
is to be consumed
it is to be taken up
into participation in something larger
than the self
uh
hint god is what he's talking about
there right now it's taken up into
participation some something someone we
might say larger than the self yet in
such a way in which the identity of the
self is paradoxically secured i know
that um that's a mouthful there's a lot
going on that quote especially that last
line might leave you a little bit like
well huh
the self is paradoxically secured that
guy's an academic yeah kavanaugh is an
academic um
but i think what he's naming
is that i remember peter talked about
the will of god
and i think sometimes
we think um to surrender to god
means um
basically that like in a bad way in an
unhealthy way i'm going to lose me
i'm i'm not going to have any more
agency
right any more
kind of say in a sense of like
of uh what i like what i don't like um
my personality right we might even fear
like god's gonna change me or something
like change you not necessarily in a
good way but in a bad way like it's
almost the um the idea of the
obliteration of myself like i'm i'm
gonna be extinguished
and because you know but it's all for
the will of god you know it's just well
that's that's just what you gotta do
it's the sacrifice we all gotta make
sure no one likes it
but that's just how it is you know like
that's how maybe we could hear it in um
that weird way but um i don't think
that's at all what um kavanaugh's
actually saying um
and i i think the kind of the key line
here
is
um
well let's come back to verse two you
won't spend the rest of your lives
chasing your own desires but you will be
anxious to do the will of god how we
could hear that is oh great now i'm just
going to be a robot
for god
no more fun for me
just i don't know
obeying the will of god
and uh i don't remember i was uh i
remember people would say like i'm
afraid if i surrender to god he's gonna
make me a missionary
this is gonna or a pastor
you know
i like being faster
but uh right because we kind of have
these fears like what if i surrender god
and i remember um actually uh maggie my
wife who's teaching she was really
afraid to kind of surrender to god in
high school because she liked me
and she's really afraid that she like
surrendered to god
you know that of course
the first thing he's gonna say is well
you have to give up your boyfriend
you know like isn't this weird these
images of god but that we have like can
you see the image of god operating there
it's like this weird kind of fear-based
person this sort of kill joy you know
who just god wants to make you miserable
and so don't you dare surrender you know
he's not safe you know like that is so
that's not who jesus has revealed god to
be
which is why i think kavanaugh says
actually
this is
beautiful it's to be caught up in some
something in someone larger than
yourself
it's to find a sense of purpose and
meaning and beauty because god knows who
you are and he knows like who he made
you to be and he knows what's going to
bring you joy
and so to actually choose god's way is
not oh great no more parties for me you
know like no it's not just about it's
it's a it's about um the goodness of god
flowing into your heart and mind and and
overcoming you in other words um
you know oneness with the god who is
father son and spirit is your highest
freedom
because it's the very purpose you've
been created for as saint augustine said
our hearts are restless
until what
until they rest in
you
that's the end of the chase scene
is when we have that that experience
that encounter with god and it's like he
um god um
meets us in such a beautiful way that
we're never the same again
one way we might put it is um well we
tend to think of it as sin you know like
sin is freedom
and then obeying the will of god is
shackles that's sometimes how we think
of it you know
um but actually it's the opposite sin is
not freedom but slavery
for freedom is not simply the capacity
to do whatever i want
whenever i want to um as any addict can
tell you
right we don't look at someone who's
intensely addicted to be like wow
what freedom
look at you you're doing the thing you
say you want to do
right it's like yeah freedom it's not
that simple it's not just like do
whatever i want so i'm free
no no freedom
is is actually the is
um resting in the will of god
experiencing the birth of the divine
life within you
i know that last line might also sound
very highfalutin and mystical you know
that the divine life within you what is
what does that mean i think jesus called
it the heart
the apostle paul called it the true self
uh the christian mystic meister eckhart
who recorded a few weeks back he um he
called it the divine spark
but basically what they are all naming
is that there is this place very very
deep within each one of us
this place where
you and god
meet
and this is true for everyone
why because you're made in the very
image
and likeness of god
right not in some physical like you look
like god you know like
not in that sense right but but god made
you
and so there's this deep place
and
and when you learn to live from that
place
goodness
and love enjoy not only find you
but it starts to flow out of you
to others
and that's why i said that is the
highest freedom
that's not
slavery to the will of god you know in
some bad sense like that's um that's
freedom
i um and you can hear in that how that's
the opposite of the rolling stones song
right in consumer culture the endless
striving chasing running craving
desiring
hungry thirsty for but never satisfied
um
there's i came across a teaching um i'll
close with a few this teaching and a few
stories then i'll be done but um it's a
teaching from an ancient mystic named
sono
and she was she wasn't a christian
different religious tradition but she
was
she had a lot of wisdom
and um
she taught her followers
um a little saying
uh to try to kind of draw them towards
god
and
she basically advised them to
say this when they met any and every
life situation
and the statement was this thanks for
everything
i have no complaints
whatsoever
that's challenging
do you think
like wait any and every life situation
like this is i love that at least a part
of me when i heard that quote i thought
that's the craziest thing i've ever
heard
um
and
uh
just to be clear i wouldn't like i don't
know in like a pastoral sense i would
never like show up like if you're in the
deepest of grief you know be like well
remember the teaching of sono thanks for
everything i have no complaints
whatsoever so make sure you say you know
um i think um obviously
there's moments where i i don't i just
expect people to just like ah you know
but um
what's interesting though is that so
much of our life actually isn't those
moments of like deepest grief and loss
you know actually most of our life is
like 10 000
annoying little things
and what's so easy to slip into
is a mode of constant complaint
right where it's just like
um
i reject this
like i i don't accept this i don't
accept my life
i just don't right it's like this sense
this inner we don't maybe say it out
loud but it's sort of there in our
complaints you know in my complaint i
mean i'm not trying to put this on you
all this is this is me too like there's
just something deep that's like
i just i don't like i just i'm i'm not
happy and i can't be happy here right
because that's the live consumer culture
you need something
right
you need to buy something
and then
it'll happen for you right like if you
just had a new thing of information if
you just said like
and and so too to say
thanks for everything i have no
complaints whatsoever i i wonder like
what if that's actually
living into the will of god
um in a really deep and powerful way to
say god
oh
this is my life
and i trust that it's from you
and so
thank you
for it
even though this is like
kind of sucky right now
you know but you're faithful and good in
the midst of it
um
again it's not about like just the big
things
you know like it's about the 10 000
little things so i'm going to share with
you a few very little stories from my
life i recognize these are petty and
ridiculous
but they mattered to my little heart
um
so about two weeks ago we had a
a evening weekday evening soccer game
and um
that's you know that's fine it was fine
but it was just one of those
long days you know i mean you work all
day and then it's like you get the you
rush to dinner and then you like get out
the door and you get there slightly late
and you know it's just the whole you're
like and i'm coaching so it's like you
know getting my plan and all the things
and then like coach the game okay it was
fine it was fine but it's one of those
things where it ends you know i don't
know eight-ish and so by the time we get
home it's like 8 30 and we're just said
if you know we've ever been in the kids
stage just like you don't want to be an
hour and a half past the bedtime routine
or at least starting it so it's just you
know you're just behind it's just one of
those moments you know and so we get
home we pull in
and i'm tired and um
one of my children pipes up from the
back seat
i left my sandals at the field
i left my sandals and i'm just sitting
there
and uh
i turned
and i looked at them in the look of fear
on their face i think they knew
like this is bad timing also
this is our child who forgets you know
they're sandals or it's usually a
different thing but they forget it all
the time
all the time every day
it's just
it's eighth or we're just we're tired
you know and so i'm just sitting there
and i turn
and i promise you i had heard this sonos
teaching about maybe two weeks before
that and those words come into my mind
thanks for everything i have no
complaint whatsoever and i just turned
and i smiled and i said
remember to take responsibility for your
things
and this child is like
okay
is that all
and i was like yes
you can go
and you know what here's the thing like
max and i talked a minute we decided she
did the bedtime i would drive you know
so i get and i drive and you know what
here's the thing it was fine it was fine
it's fine i drove to the field i looked
around thankfully we not only left the
sandals we left a hoodie we left a few i
called articles so it was good that i
got you know i mean and i gathered up
the things and i walked back to my car
and i drove home and you know what like
it was it was fine
it was fine the life god's given me it's
fine is it perfect is it flawless no
but it's it's good you know it's a good
life
about five days after that i um at that
time hadn't had a haircut in a long time
and uh
it's getting crazy in my
neck i know this is a weird story but
i'm sorry it's what came to me uh you
know my the neck hair is kind of growing
you know i mean it needs to be trimmed
you know gentlemen you know got to get
the trim you know and so i knew we
didn't have time for like the whole
haircut but i was like i just need a
quick and so i went to my childhood
again i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot
and i was like hey
can you just help me with this like
before work and before school like just
real quick just i don't know maggie was
busy
he helped me
and this child's like
a little nervous you know like sure
and i was trying to explain what to do
but it alas it did not matter and just
kind of
it was like an inch it was just too high
um
it was just too high
i walk in the door afterwards in the
kitchen and maggie goes oh my gosh
oh
um i know you're very particular about
your hair are you okay that's literally
what you said to me
okay
and of course maggie and i had talked
about all this you know and so i looked
at her and i said
thanks for everything
i have no complaints whatsoever
and again you know what like
it was fine
and so i looked a little bit like an
idiot for a few days until i could get a
real haircut and like you know once i
got it real short then you can't really
tell i don't think maybe you if you can
tell don't tell me because i'm feeling
more confident right now you know like
okay um
but but the point is you know like um
it's
it's fine this is the life god's given
me and sometimes i'm an idiot sometimes
my kids sometimes like
but at the end of the day there's
something about just receiving our life
with
gratitude and joy
because you know honestly being
reactionary
is slavery
you know the freakouts the constant
you know over dumb crap like it's just
not worth it
forcing the outer world
to be perfect
is
impossible
can consuming to find satisfaction
leads to a place of emptiness but to
receive our life as a gift from god to
actually show up for our life
like that's divine
that's beautiful that's that's the birth
of the divine life within you that's the
holy spirit filling you and meeting you
and and when we can do that that's how
we start living with a sense of joy with
a sense of gratitude no longer having to
chase some
perfection but but just being grateful
for the life god has given us
so
so as we come to the table of the lord
tonight
may it be
not just another act of
you know
consuming
but but may it be a moment
where we receive
god
and um
as we receive
may um god
consume you
take you up into
his life
so
this is the table
not of the church but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself
[Music]
so
if you would like to stand with us we're
going to close with this last song
and um
the lyrics
are talking about i just want more i
just want more i just want more which
seems maybe a little contradictory to
what brett was talking about but
it's really posturing ourselves
to desire
more of
that divine spark more of
that
purpose
the one who created us the one who knows
us
to want more of that
to fulfill us
so if y'all want to sing this along with
us
[Music]
i just want more
more of you
god
i just want more
[Music]
lay down all i
am
making room for you
lord i'm ready
to open up my heart
to receive not in part but the fullness
of who
you are lord i'm ready
i just want more
i just want
more of you
[Music]
i just want more
of you
i pour out all i have
i know i am
making room for you
lord i'm ready
to open up my heart
to
receive the
[Music]
i'm fullness
i just want
[Music]
more of you
now come and reach into my heart
come and heal every part
i want more of you
just one touch from your robe steals the
weakness
[Music]
come and reach into my heart
from
[Music]
i need more
i just want more
[Music]
come
steals the weakness
[Music]
just
thank y'all so much that is beautiful
wonderful thank you mindy and team
um i really do hope and pray
that
you found something heard something felt
something and tonight that really
administered to you and you take it into
this next week filled with hope and fuel
for another week of being yourself
and finding jesus in the big and the
really tiny moments as well
um
if you call the table home we invite you
to give financially you can do that
online or there's a little box at the
back there's also a box at the back that
if you're a visitor we would love for
you to fill out or if you're attending
online please reach out to us we would
love to hear your story get to know you
and just welcome you to our table you're
always welcome here
after service i will be standing at the
back if you would like to pray or you
want to hug
i am there and would love to pray over
you as you go into this week and i have
a beautiful benediction that i would
like to speak over you if an addiction
is just a prayer
over your week a blessing so you can
open your hands and close your eyes or
you can just stand and receive this
and then you'll
go about your your week
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day so as you go into
your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
in jesus name amen
you